hey friends I'm joining you from a
foreign location you know actually in
the middle of a biosphere known for its
genetic diversity and other
uh tremendous artistic Delights so I
can't keep this very long but I'm on my
way back to San Diego tonight be back
there tomorrow
and uh would like to catch you all up
with uh Professor Avi Loeb of his
seemingly outrageous claims that he's
found unequivocal evidence
for extraterrestrial technology that was
discovered courtesy of I am one
Interstellar meteor one meteorite in
this case it landed on Earth in the
ocean off the coast of the beginning
South Pacific I'm gonna schedule an
interview with Avi in the not too
distant future so let me know what
questions you have for him and I will
post them right here thanks for joining
me stay tuned for much more Brian
Keating